and there's been a lot of talk about
different virtues like courage
Temperance over the course of this
dialogue Socrates according to alabes is
the guy who has these how do we know
that well he's got Temperance which has
to do with regulating your your desires
and your pursuit of pleasure because he
doesn't sleep with this this kid who's
trying to seduce them who everybody else
in the town see seems to want to sleep
with so imagine you know uh put in put
in our context um you know whatever
whatever way your casaste go some super
model of the uh who's rich and and
charming and Brilliant um besides they
want to hang out with you because they
want to sleep with
you are you able to say this we probably
should think this through where do you
sleep with them Socrates says let's
think it through he is temperate